when I started talking to the producer
yet produced a film of mine called the
Skylab which is a film that's a very
personal film and then he wanted to do
you know a film a comedy with me we
started talking and there was one film
that came to my mind that I had watched
when I was a kid was called the bad seed
oh yes patty mccormack yes and I was
like I love this film and you know and
then another film came to my which was
Lolita and I was I you know I I know
it's not like Lolita but originally I
wanted something more like Lolita a
little more you know like the i don't
know i won't get into it because in the
end I could have never find financing
for it so but but I decided to go into
that idea of the bad seed and to make it
more of a comedy because there's
something about like sociopath that I
think is funny when you don't actually
when it's not in real life you know
there's something about dark characters
I mean I think you know my parents
brought me to see a lot of films when I
was a kid and I remember when it came
out seeing a king of comedy which is
about basically everyone's a psychopath
in it and and and I remember people were
laughing but they were nervous at the
same time and I really enjoyed that
feeling you know there were moments that
could have gone very wrong that could
have gone too dark or too light how did
you maintain a balance the scene in the
balcony where you know Lolo is getting
throttled by show honey I mean yeah it
goes very far i mean the film is like a
french forest meets you know kind of
like a film about like something that's
pretty dark you know I always lie i
enjoyed liked walking that fine line
between like you know it Lolo is really
a terrible human being but at the same
time you know it's funny because he's
also like a child you know what he does
is really like a child I mean he uses
itchy powder you know he's instead of
real polonium yeah instead of polonium
it's too expensive polonium I've checked
on the darknet it's really really
expensive it's like 1.6 million euros
for one milligram of pulling it's very
expensive you know they killed a rester
that's why you didn't use it or you
thought it was funny night not it was
fun
that he looks for polonium but he ends
up with eg powder you know he's like he
could be the master of destruction but
he's really just using itchy powder you
know at the Harbor you have two
different relationships of course a
mother-son relationship and then a woman
who's in her 40s who's finding love all
over again and this is its triangle and
but also very different 2 by 2 emotional
Act yeah I mean I wanted to mix you know
I ended up mixing a few things in the
film which is like a woman finding love
and I mean a woman and a man finding
love in their 40s like starting life
again you know there's always this idea
that kind of not always this idea but in
some films like it's almost like if
you're in your 40s your life is kind of
over or you know it's like it's like you
know it's funny because before I shed
this so I was talking to my agent I was
like turning 44 or whatever and I said
hey now I can play all the villain you
know I'm past 45 or whatever you know so
I'll be I'll be evil from now on this
idea that anyone over 40 is not you know
cannot fall in love cannot start a life
again doesn't have fun doesn't have you
know this I mean especially for a woman
so I I just I just wanted to show women
that are happy having fun being silly
and sexual fee being sexual being being
happy and crazy and you know having all
sorts of emotions and and being fine
with it also being being feeling good
with themselves even if they're neurotic
you know it's okay i mean it's like
talked up a little bit about the casting
of lolo and shawna lenee two actors whom
you knew already yes so not actually a
Lulu I wrote it for him van saun like us
he's a young actor I worked with him on
the Skylab and I did also with a
carrying VR she was also in the Skylab
of film you'll never see because no one
will never buy it in this country and so
just I just tell you that's the truth
but basically it's a I loved working
with them and Van song is a wonderful
actor Karen VR who plays ariana is a
wonderful actress and I wrote it
them in mind caffeine told me you know i
don't really play supporting parts
anymore because she became a big star in
between the time we showed the two films
and i didn't know that so you know I
wrote her apart and I say I'll write you
really really dirty dirty lines and I I
swear people remember you in the film so
I went for it you know with the lines I
was I had really fun doing those dirty
dirty lines but I mean like writing them
was a lot of fun and so and saying them
and acting them and filming them and
editing them and anyway so and so and
then vessel I loved working with him on
the Skylab he's so super professional
super smart super funny he's kind of a
brilliant kid so I wanted to work with
them again was this also a cautionary
tale about an indulge generation of kids
do you know a Violetta no no you know I
know kind of like this kind of situation
for some parents you know this is an
extreme version of it but I also wanted
to do an extreme version of it i mean my
idea behind all this is like you know i
show the film leisure tea in it which is
about the end of humanity it's kind of
like the film is about like this new
generation of people with maybe you know
kind of this lack of empathy and maybe
kind of as a society becoming you know
kind of the end of the world kind of
thing i know this is it's just a
romantic comedy but it's really about
the end of the world because we're all
becoming sociopath and we we don't care
about what we're doing to each other
anymore and destroying everything so
that's what it's a bit that's what the
film is really about there it's really
about the end of the world is it every
film about you you got to work with the
DP cherry Arbogast and yes to what
extent is that is that relationship
responsible for the look of this film
because you even get to the artwork that
lolo produced and the look of it is very
much part of this film yeah i wanted the
film to be glossy ER in a way than my
other films you know my other films were
very handheld and kind of crazy looking
and stuff i wanted something kind of
glossy in a way i find because the
subject matter was a little darker and a
little creepy you know at times I wanted
some
kind of sweet and kind of perfect and
colorful to kind of contrast with the
dark kind of creepy side of the film
even though it's not that creepy but you
know it's a little crib I mean the kid
is a little creepy you know but anyway
so so I kind of wanted that look and
also I was very you know I mean I you
know the the artwork i mean we spend
quite some time you know I give examples
of like the journal and everything what
I wanted exactly took pictures of things
that I knew that I liked actually and
stuff I used some paintings of my own
son I shouldn't say for the painting of
him when he painted when he was a little
is first painting just that one don't
worry not the other stuff but I just
thought only a child can do that kind of
thing and I thought it was interesting
that Lolo could have like children's
painting but have you let him see the
movie though I would never let him see
the film no listen I will let him to see
the film eventually he's only seven so
first of all he's not at all interested
by my films he's always saying like
mommy why do you make movies where
people talk all the time because he sees
me in the editing room editing the film
he doesn't see the whole film and he's
so bored and he says why do you do mommy
you have to do green screen you'll
finally you'll never do you know you
yeah you have to become successful and
make green screen movies mommy this
makes no sense whatsoever I said up your
when you and your friend you Janie were
talking about this film as you dreamed
up she said this is a film about what
it's going to be like when you're little
boys that age hahaha ahaha no actually
she just had a boy uh-huh Janie my
co-writer and actually it's gonna be her
life when hurricane is that it because I
have a feeling my kid is very is
actually full of empathy I don't think
it's ever going to be any of us kids
because I think obviously you know
there's something about being a mother
and having the anxiety of raising a
child or being a parent in general not
just the mother but it's like how do you
raise a child in a way that he's a
functioning happy not self-destructive
non-destructive human being you know
it's like you how do you do it like you
know that's what I liked in bad seed is
that the parents
question like what did we do wrong maybe
they did nothing wrong maybe some people
are born I believe there's a tendency
like I feel my son was born like a happy
little you know son no matter how dark
my life was at the time and stuff I was
dealing was other stuff but he was just
happy person you know he was born happy
and you know I see kids born in
wonderful happy couple and they're not
happy they're like dark I don't know
what happens you know it's genetics I
think or something at him the music
choices were so interesting partly
because there was a jukebox selection a
sense of the kind of young love tunes
that were going through this which
suggested young love and fresh starts
again was that what you were aiming for
in the music yeah I wanted something
kind of nice I mean there's something
about you know I the truth is I truly
believe you can fall in love in your 40s
50s 60s twenties teens anytime in life
and actually when you do fall in love
it's really kind of a feeling of being
you know there's a lightness to it you
know it's great you know I and I believe
it doesn't really you know I think I
think the characters are really in love
there's something very sweet about their
their their relationship at the end of
the bad seed the movie was so unsettling
that they had to do this little coda
where patty mccormack comes out as patty
mccormack and this is and I'm just like
a real girl I'm not a murderer but in
your film we get Sabine coming out of
the bathroom giving via let a really
dirty look really dirty Lee well because
the film is kind of constructed like a
thriller or horror film in a way you
know it like that's like the famous shot
at the end of carrie when the hand comes
out of the grave that was kind of like
what I was thinking no because I love
Carrie you know like the hand at the end
like it's like the last image of the
film like this idea that you know it's
never ending the horror of children
but you didn't have this right manner
under life is never over and what listen
I love my son don't get me wrong my son
is a little angel he's actually not at
all like destroying my religion even
though even though he's doing he's
smarter than lolo what he does is that
he's so cute and loving that you give
all the attention and you forget about
your actual life but it's it's another
way of doing it no itching powder
neither no achieve better no no I think
it might know it's please it's like it's
a movie obviously now I want to make
sure because you know so please thank
julie delpy the writer director thank
you in this film